i have 100 islands and chris how many
people are in that circle looks like
about a hundred
we're gonna give everybody their own
island okay
and whoever builds the best looking
island gets a ten thousand dollar
vacation to an island you can go
anywhere in the world and we'll pay for
it
everyone was just tp to an island and
now they're gonna start building it what
kind of island is grass and dirt buddy
this dude's already got a tree this guy
already built a nether portal
oh we got a guy making a peter oh this
guy's destroying
parts of his island to make it look more
natural yeah i'm seeing a lot of that
what's up everybody whoever builds the
best island
the most majestic and beautiful island
will get a 10
000 vacation to wherever you want in the
world
or you can just take the ten thousand
dollars in cash whatever you want yeah
bro i'm not just taking the money
good luck everybody i hope you win i
gave this kid a bunch of turtles
i like turtles could we have the duty of
placing animals on their islands
chandler's island had pigs so i think
it's only fair we put pigs on all the
islands everyone
pick up pick up pick up pick up the pie
lord eight it's probably gonna be like
why are there pigs here
let's see how many pigs i can put up
here before this guy gets mad and knocks
him off
a buoy hey come on man come on don't hit
my pigs
i like this oh he's got a bar like a
little
uh kitchen area chandler tp to me you'll
like this island
chain chance mickey dude hey what this
villager got
bro the ice cream machine don't work
here chris tp to me tp to me
right now does this remind you of
something hey it's that guy
he's back and he's made a word and it
says breem
yo yankee with no bream in the first
video he said bruv meme and in the
second video he said bro meme gang
and now it's bro plus meme equals breen
who is this guy i just want to remind
everybody that's watching that couldn't
get into the challenge that guy gets in
just
to troll look at how crazy this is dude
it's actually turning out pretty
beautiful
wow look at the pigs bruh
what is what is this oh no
what did they do why is this happening
my hopes and dreams
all right that's some bonus points right
there there's some creativity there look
at this it's like one of our
like survival like challenge videos his
island is good but there's nothing like
crazy like it's all kind of basic
blazing vacuums
yes uh you know the challenge is to
build a really awesome island right
yes it is well this is a boat that'd be
a boat but then there's also going to be
an island
hit us with your funniest joke this will
affect our rating on you man walked into
a bar
okay said ow i moved him
wait come over here look this one's
islands are floating
oh bro the blue flame disney freak 11
in my opinion this is the best so far i
love the uh
colors of this tree thingy yo ostrich oh
wait this one says chandler's ostrich
very nice
oh wait what is this what do i see in
the distance looks like somebody trying
to
cater to you all i'm saying is if an
island said shot mr beast it'd be a cool
island
i just want to let you know jimmy when
we're judging and i see an island
using podzol this is the ugliest block
in minecraft it literally just looks
like a
pile of poop oh this one has an umbrella
in beds
what the heck hold on if i mind if i
catch a tan
you actually do look tanner oh anyway
here's a baby yoda for your girlfriend
she likes that right yes let me call her
uh will she pick up
oh this one's so good this is a tiki bar
oh look at um dinner bone upside down in
the boat
i'm too lazy to exit minecraft to tell
carl and chandler to join so i'm just
gonna yell
carl join back join the discord
chandler let's join back into the other
call hey festive how's it going it's
been pretty good
just building my island i was just kind
of curious if you did win where would
you go on a vacation to
um probably somewhere in europe all
right thank you festive
hey redactive are you in the call yeah
redacted the reason i moved you in here
is because i'm curious if you win
where are you going to take your
vacation to i don't know
redacted is there anything you want to
say uh subscribe to mr beast
oh my goodness look at how beautiful
this shot is
they've been working hard yo is that a
waterfall i've never even seen this
thing before what is this
how did he do this this is easily the
coolest one so far
all right chris yes ten minutes left ah
oh
guys we have a problem he cross borders
all right star wars is great are you in
here
yeah what did you spend the five grand
on i've got a new computer
but now why i added you to the call
follow me over here turn around
do you see this right here star wars yes
this is your neighbor competitor
and he built into your space this is
[ __ ] up we need to settle this like
men
command tech notes so you and star wars
this great are going to have to duel and
if you don't beat star wars it's great
we're going to have to remove you from
the competition all right and we broke
them out
they're now free oh oh he's got the high
ground anakin
oh no oh
oh oh oh
it was so close star wars this great one
command
sadly has to leave rules are rules is
this doofenshmirtz evil incorporated oh
my gosh it is
oh it is wait i i didn't even see that
oh let's go oh you win for sure i think
you need some parrots though oh look at
this somebody put techno blade with a
bunch of pigs
look inside for a surprise i think he's
still building the surprise
chris yeah five minutes they're almost
done
yo this guy figured out how to use tnt
so wait he's just blowing everything up
shot mr beast.com oh oh well when you
put it that way it's okay
he's changing the oh oh so you change it
to use code chris when i'm over here no
don't even act like you like me right
when he saw you he instantly put use
code chris
oh this person's building the teen
titans because the teen titans is on
an island this is cool it's going to
win and time is up stop the building
gentlemen it is time to judge the
islands but
before we judge you judgey what are we
judging for epicness
originality aesthetic i'd say
epicness majesticness originality
i i don't know if the second one was a
word majesticness is just a hard word to
say i'm sorry
let's start off with this island it has
a parrot it has one singular parrot
this is actually pretty creative all
right here's what we're gonna do if we
know an island won't win we're not gonna
raid it
like obviously this right here like it's
cool but obviously it's not gonna win
but this one what are these wait this is
lay pig in a cage
i give it a four this is a ten i'm gonna
give it a four yeah i'll give it a five
all right his score is 23. next this
one's just a bunch of trees
normie this one's just a bunch of trees
with the house normie
all right this one is cool only because
it has this weird color vine that i did
not know existed
look we got a hot tub we got an eating
area you can't get on the chairs
normally i give it a two out of ten
hey jimmy imma keep it a buck 50 with
you if you were able to jump on the
chairs that's
that would have won easy oh my gosh
there's a lot going on here
oh my god got some stuff going on what
is this
what is this ginormously tall palm tree
world's largest tree i get a six i've
seen a bigger tree that's a three out of
ten
all right well now he can't win i could
i didn't want a rate that's fine
i look like a hillbilly pointing to
chandler winning
wait wait wait guys oh no i see what
this is
oh this is him losing the island this is
carl losing the island
carl's so tiny because carl is tiny carl
and you are like relatively the same
height
i'm about an inch taller than coral
carlin you are relatively the same
height
i'm an inch taller chris we're back at
the boat what do you have to say now i
think the boat
shipwrecked on the island growing into
it is quite exquisite
i'm going to give it an eight i'd say
seven i'm gonna go ahead and throw a
seven out there
um i'll give it a six oh wait no the
parrot's on a leash it's an eight
it's now a nine he got 30 points out of
40 and it's currently in the lead
hey look at this really good sweet sign
here really sweet hi whoever reads this
i want to know that i'm really happy
that i get to be in a mr b
challenge i don't care if i win all
right he doesn't care everyone's next
ah doofenshmirtz
hey everybody listen up i know you're
all giant nerds and you think this is
the coolest thing ever 10 out of 10. but
if we are being objective the rest of
the island is empty
but it is on an island what are our
three ratings epicness
majectis-ness and originality okay i get
what you're saying jimmy i get what
you're saying with all that taken into
consideration i'm gonna go ahead and
give it a 10.
chris what is your rating nine i
honestly would say it's like
a seven taylor what do you rate it eight
and a half this person got 34 and a half
points
he's currently in first place by a large
margin all right anyways next
what are we rating shot mr beast i give
it a 10 out of 10. for no reason
whatsoever oh
okay but the pigs are named
shopminsterbeast.com three
a two all right well now he can't win
next time we judge the one you guys have
not stopped talking about this entire
video
he or she didn't finish the back yeah i
don't know if i can give it a 10.
it's not finished kerbal hey first off
the boys really like the structure
thank you but carl had a really
important question to ask you carl go
for it
is it team titans or teen titans go teen
titans
yeah good job good job good job kerbal
i'm sorry but
because the back's not finished that is
going to affect your score chris
hmm what stop oh i'm on your side kerbal
just letting you know
chris what do you rate it 10. why
because it's a teen titans island teen
titans 10.
i'm gonna be honest that's a simple nine
out of ten if i've ever seen one i'm
gonna give this an eight
trailer give it a ten so doofenshmirtz
doesn't win seven
that brings the total to 34. call give
it a ten
carl give me ten no taxi back seat why
would you do that you idiot
it's all your fault carl i'm not the
person that gave it a seven
i'd rate the baby yoda 10 out of 10 but
my girlfriend won't answer the phone so
it's all your girlfriend's fault alright
guys what do we rate hi by
i'm too sad to rate right now zero this
zero someone worked hard on this someone
worked hard on this
guys there's only two left i mean i give
this a
six and a half yeah it's like a okay
like six
seven all right well then guys that
means this is the last island
which is like a four i mean like the
trees are cool but it's
he literally just planted trees did we
just accidentally let doofenshmirtz win
i think doofenshmirtz won yeah ain't no
accident about it i love durban squirts
rocky boy welcome to the call do you
know why i added you here uh i do not
see that teen titans go thing over there
you lost by half a point to it
really yeah and by you i mean the person
who built that you actually won by half
a point yeah you beat him by half a
point with doofenshmirtz
where are you vacationing to you know i
don't know i can just give you ten
thousand dollars in cash if you prefer
that can i
just have ten thousand dollars in cash
yeah ten thousand dollars thank you for
watching hit that subscribe button bye